[Music]
amazing
I think we are
[Music]
and we'll have more information about
that later and one of the interesting
here's something special for starters
[Music]
also I'm excited to announce that we
went international the summer and in
September we launched our first data in
Jakarta Barcelona we had hundreds of
attendees from 20 different countries
[Music]
we're continuing to expand nationwide
these are the leaders from Iran as I
mentioned they're growing all the time
and we're all 16 community organizers
who are connected to debate avenge and
data science base so if you're here from
another city and want to get in touch
with us about what it takes to start of
data and speed up your support we also
like to think of ourselves so if you
anything that doesn't meet your
standards in any way please email us to
reach us and we're always looking for
feedback we want us to be a super
inspiring meaningful technical event for
the community
[Music]
yeah we're always having to feel that to
the roof of the future so I think
there's two tracks that we have this
year were always playing with the
content areas of the conference we have
a coordinated engineering track could be
in this room we have our data science
and analytics drop which is doors
[Music]
in
[Applause]
[Music]
do a lot with few resources so again
typically into the track but someone who
has a full staff appreciation of what we
use to build the data product I remember
the very first talk that the attention
of four years ago was by the Spotify and
they told us a story about how they had
built up end-to-end discovery and this
is before describe our weekly was really
a big givers watching at the time and it
was a great example of an engineer who
had sort of a product sense but was able
to
[Music]
and if you want to stay connected with
us there the first place where you can
get the speaker slides
these are awesome sponsors we have so
many of them this year
they're all here they're in their teams
some of the really cool interesting data
tools that they can devil for you
so we don't know how dedicated sponsor
time when we tell you to go and talk to
them because that would be stupid
instead we enter people also encourage
you to work before that he was chief
performance of architect Africana so
suffice it to say that folks understand
the internal workings of database
performance
[Music]
which is
as well
[Music]
then we get some cereal now some portion
of our process equation with a
serialized attraction and I'm using the
universal scalability laws notation of
Sigma here for this material as a
fraction so that's what it starts to
look like we start to level off and
eventually Asian that's exactly what
queueing does queueing is when access to
a resource is restricted so I mentioned
that there's an
[Music]
and you can drive
all right so all right so that I think
is actually
interesting
[Music]
there are
what term how to dive
so we also
[Music]
so right now
all right
[Music]
okay Kristen's worst critic very bit
extreme
I didn't do all this work there's 14 of
us to work with so introduction to
attend to our what we do to the basic
when we do better with the website but
also thinking you get treated more like
associate this is a great common goal
that's great to say more than that to do
so we return an intense for witches and
this is like a good that they're going
to talk someone else like I should say
they like you know it's allowing the
country
so the types of experiences our partners
are using this for my generation was
like depressed
[Music]
this is just one example there's a lot
of different color partners excite to
get really neat you slicing the negative
weights by these support to do different
we do work for a big company to do with
the only you'll be able to go through
this slide is that we have a lot of
spirit so we made these reduce a lot so
first we need one and a half day
searches into the circulation so this is
reasonable so that's data size what we
actually so the big do we use is
collected from apartment so that's
either event event those events log love
data here so we'll train these mobiles
and then use for real-time predictions
so there's all this new old Network
effects but again this for back to the
page so it also has to happen
ice skates with a very much
once you think the predictions very soon
to happen what I'm wearing these plates
is we just passed a pretty big back
website like doing whatever
[Music]
the whole point of being able to do this
is to rapidly experiment and get these
long tech times but at least the level
at work and if each one of those a 90 X
moment it should be flexible so that the
types of events that we're getting I
don't want to do the future trap and
whatever you think you're rich
so
[Music]
you think origin destination
it has Diana and I say what about to me
it has to calculate things like that did
your way of anybody so that was like the
one piece
[Music]
this is all the Phoenix like what
categories like those are nice so this
is the training so it's all so simple
there's no physical extract don't
remember don't have which you can apply
to other uses the original
[Music]
when it comes to discuss so I wanna call
it well so
[Music]
which is
predation request the two steps extract
a picture and a training model are
distinct status and there's a similarly
their distance that's the real world we
need to find the white multi and I'll
come back to what features that's what
this over I'm going to have a really
traded example widest it happens to be
see the preview laziness expectancy I
know the Givens expected early
predictions
meanwhile the novel a world every
trained the moment for whatever reason I
now have to hold that maybe I want to
have a green marker maybe some ways
notice other I definitely train now I
don't like interior detractors that will
produce I bet her and I'm almost
expected production concurrently serving
bubbles expected
he's the immunity that there's no the
only way to do always is if the other
kinds of informal first the other you're
going to end up in indicate whether
something is just you're either giving
the inspector which you think things
their buses gonna fail but it is going
to that's kind of worse because it looks
like this is like it looks like it's
working but it's action and that's that
consistent state persistence we managed
to push out a version now there's a kind
of deployment problem wouldn't be the
end of the world if it was like that one
deployment we
[Music]
so
so you can google qualitatively the same
if there was kind of one universal set
of configurations use wait the rest of
that kind of schedule before you guys so
[Music]
so there's no like cleverness you need
to need to just work out well so what
kinds of data
so it's kind of like the difficult ones
I think these different features
yes now we have like they what do you
mean what excuse is a purchaser in
Folsom intensive programming for like
ten communities of different kinds have
done so actually almost every client and
then come and give another baby
[Music]
but you're going to
so hunter you're a cop right there
I decided comfortable serving asking
people who predicted the purchase that's
been read the other way is this is bad
right
if you start saying hey all these
moments like I mean big difference I
mean if I'm harder to integrate with
these boards and committees they're like
holding out using it you know so we need
to be quite robust initiated we're
always serving whatever is the best
break and also understand
[Music]
so once we work that out we could be
seized other words the cohorts
so here the jaw sorry it wraps off the
jar
[Music]
each of those who agrees the chart
honestly does the training to the test
elevation and then pushes back everybody
comes and says okay to keep track of
[Music]
okay so if you wanna do it now
you start this with problem you don't
have to carry over the key point system
so the coup is go back actually one of
them now is just and the key point I
want to do with this this is the way
[Music]
the question is I will hear some office
that we're gonna start with Keynes in
room 302
I think we have a break
[Music]
history of Western six years six years
old opens to squadron personal by
Facebook internal usage basically made
us again invited because after moving
with spell so the boobs entity from
scratch completely so my connection part
of over three years by our and with the
punches which I will talk about the
major was the natural preference
essentially creates eco engines after
take a warehouse doesn't holiday traffic
on favorite format storage device for
any kind of storage and ganache
[Music]
so some of the biggest issues question
production are expensive over scooper
[Music]
so I overview architecture you enable
this problem the scale is very flexible
but essentially in logical architecture
one for me to bring up the system and
multiple whatever actual process so the
coordinator will accept a statement or
senior my education and then schedule
orchestrating the data actually our
educational career across the workers
workers themselves is a really danger
from sports and
[Music]
so most workers can be tweaked are in
power from your storage and then actual
workers they just may be either
especially okay so I just need to
dismantle our specific
and then the recipes
what's your biggest most specific
optimizations or disregard for my feed
evolved architecture completely place
search engine from one to the other
say HDFS of premises you decide to move
to the cloud right your usual completely
unaffected by true sequel users to see
the same set of tables in the same
circle together our ski mask and the
quiz will not change
that's pictures of us that I can't I
connected to the office hours
I was actually community driven focuses
project many of these will happen
especially from ecosystem like each of
us has gotta quizzes sensitive and by
vendors so you have about the solutions
over what you can use
[Music]
so that's big data there was this mantra
yeah contribute to your storage high
because shipping danger is so expensive
and it's very costly like everything is
not that's known the truth all the
modern architectures without supply
stores
[Music]
it's also related by this because you
can actually collect rest of you any of
the public cloud private cloud the
strategy of pursuing you basically and
then you have new titles for specific
storage right so in example SP becomes
also 1820 respect seems crazy but now
about safe
[Music]
all those languages right you may have a
passion about it in a second okay I want
to make sure that this runs inside first
- all right so as is Vicki I suppose
it's a personal invitation an intensity
time to go out into presto
[Music]
representing the state from the so make
things easy to survive in a spectrum
which we do right sir because with a lot
of twisted cell the poor but also we try
to make it easy to do so marketplace and
swing to gated services my scaly each
girl the skill is instances that's fine
and then if you follow the links so we
also enter
thanks mr. Kristo as an application and
all that from talking to the top storage
become big storage hi - little ships
were placed inside a party I am full of
microcytic and it's also great because
server in this case is some premises but
also it everywhere since our rights we
can use the same interface for the
producers across all those environments
they don't need to learn you syntax the
language the tools to interact okay so
the Mac user could make some internal
considerations that were part of
restaurant when things we use doesn't
well they divisive to it so the best
chapters from the classic architecture
so in many ways was the education of
dress code is very similar to what you
can find
how are they makeup is anything sexy
these are read some extent way so some
of these considerations from did which
is makes interest uniquely positioned to
charge those proprietary maybe score
solutions because is actually following
to see so anything tonight but mine is
like I was part of
[Music]
which is the first original director
across six of turning page efficiently
lots of columns
actors the moment you think it's out of
the storage is transforming each other
motivation is very efficient compared by
to compassion swing by
savior's few cycles through Castro more
efficient data structures thoroughly
into again and make it fewer
[Music]
multi-parameter executions try to get as
much as you are optimized for the human
form answer you disturbing idea polar
form at the source do please read first
during really horrible half from those
coal storage pockets to internal memory
representation is also and then recently
we produced by cosmic optimizer to
fresco which allows us to executed very
complex code is much more efficient
faster velocity school resources and
basically our total speeds of the
commercial engines to marry couples is
the presentation here and in the world
Simon elder disagree but you basically
leather statistics and better write jobs
either join you to say this and then you
just give you to the rest
[Music]
basically never regrets pursue suspect
hiding behind actually and also uncovers
the energy by this so it's actually
efficient and if you run it in the cloud
but who doesn't mean right well your
pure machines right that's great
this faster you can also Buddhists
within you to stranger plus a ten
[Music]
so so over 60% to first actually are
times X all past reprising the baseline
[Music]
it's pretty amazing to very good because
then we can choose allowed right there
are independent studies right now on the
way by transferred to other users and
the mission from her first overseas
first two verses which the rest of us
snow for the dignity technologies and
you can see how best first against ever
price but basically first oh so simple
[Music]
for some challenges
[Applause]
[Music]
generous one example
so that was true originally and is still
true because of whatever users even an
in terment basically migrated off a
bunch of pipe lights from - super small
and scale right so the magnitude and
that way they can enable some
replayability because of the benefits
was the speed they attached
so
[Music]
though honestly sometimes banker has a
wall with it because it seems to be
claiming the key server list that
actually it's more like a traditional
server so if you need to transfer to
play you're approaching your you upstart
provision capacity edit time I don't
even compare your approaching
performance with either I would say yes
so I think I was still using press the
code right it's exposing press to create
your face the basis for fulfilling so
you know honestly yeah obviously you
could community colleges right honey or
we try to hurry but you see a
connectivity really popular her record
is infrequent for years but the
unpredictable to this once in a while
not to run the big-booty you all just
have a class terminal perspective a
economic actually capacity supply cracks
the sequence to participate due to
performance you actually have to go
what's the kind of the alright so yes
[Music]
all right then we'll talk about which
honestly is really active sometimes I
all right thank you and I history use
every canary diamond to a specific
implementation and not back from Capra
since I'm going to time I chose
transactions or transactional what close
with chapter they figured that might be
interesting
so my David this is a shot rubber and
school engineering like that I'm a
member of the Bastille platform team and
facias not armed is a commercial product
at like been providing us with like
there are artists at distribution of
street processes as well as support our
underlying infrastructure we started
with DC West Apache meadows of youth
recent severe to kubernetes and culture
and we start chapter under more on these
root causes as well and that's what I
specialize in
so I because of that I contributed
tactical persistent including camp
itself I helped develop the scallop DSL
or cactus trees I never done a magic act
itself it used to be called reactive
factor it's been around for five years
is might've dipped like that me streams
these are going neat projects I heard
people check out if you want to run
attack on human edges its insurer
they're just at least they're presented
up too many virtual and if you do
Panetta definitely find that project
interesting and then these us contests
of caves at library to help write a
stateful services to run on
eCos Apache that last night
so alpaca how active is a open source
initiative to integrate disparate
systems together so it's a continuing
project
it's basically a container projects
project around all these different
actors various systems it doesn't have
any source code itself it just has
documentation might have a source code
in the future but it's a very developer
centric
set of the modules to use to connect
these systems together using at the
streams and we're going to talk about
what that means is and watch care but
but it is very similar to other projects
out there use or the Thiele operations
like a badge of channel chat can connect
a lincoln active it's not declarative
it's a solo they're just modules of
library different and just like any
other library dependencies and it helps
helps people built these reactive
integration pipelines I'm using a
principal villains back pressure which
is one of the key attributes of access
routes and you write these apps and Java
its calendar so here's a logo cloud of
the different atoms that are available I
put them into groups is there's a cloud
services so AWS s3 s2 rest maybe pops up
before Google Cloud these doors much all
the big ones
think about the sandwich the best one go
solar and then of course messenger is
for implementation and bqp intentions
like rabbit out to you JMS
and of course tapping some so the
traffic connector is the connector
Hangtown products reached and it was
formerly known as an actress reads
calendar for that reactant actor
actually three days alpaca initiative
from star there couple years ago it was
created by a company called south
partner there were five years of nasty
and eventually rather than as an
official after project so I would
remember polite
Linc's di that project they so they
brought into the under the active github
organization and as a result loudly
after commuters may believe a lot better
it's used by a lot of our clients our
commercial clients but it's probably one
of the most people most popular plant
library for people who are in this
gallery places developing scallops to
the genetic factor and it is excusing
some of our other open source projects
to Zola Dom the gum is a micro service
treatment it's used or as one of the
offices for message passing between
micro services and it's used in a
nutritional product for shipping early
next year twelve a steam pipe lines as
the basically the glue your bones into
pipelines is the because it's been
around for so long it's the top
downloaded module or alpaca cat cookies
which is that's for August when you sow
a disease let's talk about what makes
max Ruby so until you provided even see
complex event processing streaming
semantics using twelve reaction speeds
specification and it's implemented
internally using active actress so like
many old actors I persistence met
earlier that act that is the Jamie is a
JVM offense the plantation allowing you
to build that resistance here is a
regenerated to simplify Sandra meet
semantics with Indian actor systems
so those you'll know that there are was
most basic parts of them are
after a cruise and then they communicate
with one another
a synchronously like passes messages
back and forth so you can all that's
pretty low level communication power and
you can do any time you want with that
but it's really difficult to model or a
high-level abstract semantic so address
dreams was the reason the reason it was
created was to make bustering expand
things easier in various parts of ACTA
or the types of systems like building so
it reduces a lot of boilerplate and
makes it easier to you know these
consciousness systems with less
experience its billeted bronze is built
in an act after system installed but
it's I that's not supposed to the end
user and these are canvas library for
giving 10 DJB Ana projects a tablet
project insert museum they don't have to
know what actor actor time but mobiles
are giving worker at the actresses and
how access means is decide the next
slide here so the most basic acts means
the source and the sink that sort of
says if he's won that lip sync as if
he's pointing money and then you have
this arbitrary number of flows between
doing some sort of process and the data
and the big the the big difference of
three nine three another stream
processors like spark are playing for
their captor streams is that they they
support this is back pressure protocol
here and so there's two there's two
communication channels to what was
happening within next readers obviously
the user-defined methods user or flowing
demonstrated but there's also in the
upstream channel that's used for those
exact pressure protocol and roles or it
Margo why you want that pressures but
so it's basically to accommodate the
vast producers looking super proper
where you don't want to pass producer
overwhelming any of your systems
downstream so that this is allows you to
signal upstream pay to slow down so you
don't overwhelm make me crashing
physicist a lot of systems don't have
the whatever the weakest point your
system your Eastern America might be
another person to fail and oftentimes it
might not be a backup and you'll get to
cascading failure across route the
structure so backpacker is really good
to you
is there a really good way to handle
something like that and if it works for
your department so the reactor history
specification is initiative termination
for the street processes with Tom
blocking back pressure so I just need to
basically implementation of this if
portals or LC principles from the grant
manifesto which is a set of principles
to to build to help build flexible
loosely coupled scalable systems that
communicate or basically specify so this
effect was spearheaded by like men but
it has a lot of issues from very big
companies industries like Netflix and
Red Hat envelope and others so I think
like I said I agree quantum computation
through several jb annotation separately
in disappeared
there's implementations other language
one times two is not specifically to the
JVM and it was also opposed to be in the
JDK and it was accepted I'm not too long
ago so as indicated on there is a set of
types under this planet is semantically
equivalent once once to work with with
all of the terms
Becca so what we're gonna see is over
time once he moves past Jetta 80 will
probably probably see most people
configure JDK 11 or once most of the
community has group there a lot of these
libraries are gonna start having
releases that uses implementations of
their own internal decisions so this is
a demo on how backpressure works so each
each source floor signior is represented
by an actor behind the scenes and
there's several important traitors of
that actor one is that each each actor
has his the mailbox in this bill does is
basically the where the messages have
buffer before they actually enter an
actor to be processed by each each one
of these components that they're called
for our stages will start due to that
turn from now on each one of these
ground stages like an actor only
processes one message at a time and
that's what makes it easy in in actor
systems to model concurrency not to
worry about you know another other
threaded part over to see you stay your
path you should like be Rihanna and just
give you that isolation and if you want
developers use have more actors and they
all have their own mailbox this is in
they can kind of do things but but
having by having fun by by processing
oneness you get a lot of flexibility in
defining state and that's the third
thing each one of these perhaps they
just can encapsulate state kept its own
to begin the demo
when you start your at the stream
there's nothing happening as though
messages flowing until all the sink
realizes that it has no message is
processed and there is no downstream
mess rap stone gives us the into line so
it it is sin is a demand requests
upstream so that this uses that back
pressure channel like I showed on the
river side it says demand request
upstream it propagates to the flow the
flow doesn't have high messages to give
it to it it moves up to the source and
then the source does what the source
dozen votes Massachusetts in this case
is floating gromek at a topic but you
could use another packet and whatever
once the what's the source as some
messages available it does that the flow
is waiting room desiccant so in sentence
messages as well and then the floral is
processing messages and satisfies the
command request rumensin and sends
messages to it so the way to get into a
little more detail of how this works you
can imagine so so a lot of people call
[Music]
process of streaming a pull model where
downstream things are pulling messages
upstream and it could be inherently
slower naive implementation so if you
have you can I have one request one
demand request per message and obviously
these messages are going to get a lot of
chatter on that communication channel so
the way around that is to is to request
one wetness so how do we figure out the
messages we can come down so that's
where these L boxes come into play so
and then a normal actresses the acronym
boxes and if you don't specify
a different one it's the default one is
unfounded
so if you grow large you'd imagine in
certain scenarios that they can grow so
large that we basically run endemic so
buddy boat excuse the mailboxes
procrastinator about it so it was
exactly how many messages you can buffer
and that's what it sentence when it
sentences demand requests says I can
handle exactly this many messages in my
mailbox and practice to be able one more
than that and it sends that Officer
Commanding request upstream that's
basically the pull side of this demand
pull that we're going over in level and
then source can then push messages
demonstrator so it doesn't need to wait
for automatic message it knows you can
send it back which is basically
workhorse antics during their business
back sending things as fast as possible
and if there's no back door for them you
can get into trouble with that level but
because it don't and/or since that's
what it says
so this is a this is the example of a
producer slow consumer drawn learn and
this is how we handle it I have screens
so once this mailbox is full
there's no more demanding a question
coming from employment so this this
situation should never happen message
sent but if it did it would be dropped
because it can't be so join hands so
there's there's the distributed system
value all told her all those ratings the
same relatively simple architecture
and it puts a lot of complexity to
clients so after capture connector it is
is the example one of those clients that
when some or complex behavior over
toggle tactic or interesting message
boards endings has really good absorbing
the high load
so it is sort of counter to what akka
Street is all about history is about
calming just enough data you can tune
the mailboxes and whatever it's to
accommodate more messages you can scale
the matter horizontally and accommodate
more load that way Mechanica doesn't
have any meetings of back pressure
it just it's designed to probably as
much as possible it's like the shock
absorber or your internal infrastructure
but on the periphery said like high
burst like spikes of traffic and Indian
consumers potential at their own speed
but I meant by that history when it
connects when it loads the other firm
affected Canton propagate back pressure
messages over through connector unless
you model that whatever their dear
little bit that doesn't make sense
because that's not the cactus
strong see it anyway so usually I wanted
her Python using ancestry is starting
with the chakra and then there are other
components and in communicating with
over three different beads so now turn
attack the topics but maybe through just
a TCP socket or a generator system
connection and those those needs of the
community you can support back pressure
trigger so back pressure is just you
know a single application you have
running on one no it can be it can span
multiple network hops as long as those
network support some meaning on the back
so I already gave you examples examples
kerosene over TCP sockets so what when
would we use a laptop or tapestry so the
very similar they're both like just
libraries like spy recorder or flink
which are pretty much require a custom
resources engineer in place to do many
large workloads on that exact extremes
are just library dependencies you bring
in to achieve your mat and then it's up
to you to figure out how they deploy
that scale if you need to but one of
them obviously better is one feature
that a lot of these other stream
processors don't have so that that's
interesting to you then this is probably
good technology like facism complex
event processing so in most cases you
want a CTP you're calling every other
systems which can be a variable activity
but the fact is trees as you might
imagine it has very good education with
after active systems and macro systems
are a great way to model very complex
business requirements you can have
active systems that are simple JP active
their products to be immensely
stream themself or they've had
clustering to the tissues as bad as many
nodes as one the effort in one spun up a
pretty poor at the cluster and the
cluster formed after five minutes
it's amazingly amazingly powerful way in
to model complex systems if you have
that so basically if you want you have
the earlier model all the rules all of
all the time
what happen to this message as it gets
processed her to see a complex CPU then
you can easily link to those macro
systems using access routes by just
using what's called the acid and I got
one time to get into that today but
[Music]
currently rejected everything and then
conflicts perhaps so sparkly chemistry
uses parts an elder all the only support
basically grasp
Ashby's actually allows you to implement
cycles with the Year graphic you had
that how many people have that name but
it's definitely pretty pretty
interesting you have that model very
easily without having to you know
basically model higher-level through to
recap topics and things like that so
what I mean by cycle is just a loop
within your I plan so instead of just
kind of a linear downstream I plan you
could have maybe a a downstream flow
sending messages to an upstream flow or
whatever reasons to influence that
information somehow that's Blanco River
so here is some code number eight
addresses this is just the ceremony and
get the clients running this code here
where the catalyst a little familiar
this is Skeletor by the way and yeah so
you can use a use types a trick-taking
governor people playing or protuberance
config in there and then some other big
he said all the settings this way and
then he was more interesting sample of
an actual an end-to-end workflow the
various is black stream and these are so
this minimal source and
we'll see here are components of the old
Africa so this is basically what
referencing and your investment or that
community details or topic subscription
and this particular source is using
basically helping to model at least one
semantics by including offset make sure
the messages are consuming downstream so
that they can eventually be ended
automatically on your behalf for you so
you know yourself so you all your
business like in some form of
transformations here like a map or lots
of other transformations that are
available and then like I said once the
dog comes back this will automatically
that you know every single message or a
batch and how do you want to model one
with those vintage so normally this
presentation I jump in the consumer
groups managing at least one semantics
or detail better I have a lot of time so
I chose one particular feature of
transactional I sort of capture and
[Music]
mention cactus supports transactions as
of 0:11
I came over June 28 last year so
transaction and they will atomic rays
multiple traffic topics and petitions
all the messages included in
transactional successively be reading
from nominal fee so the collection sound
pretty familiar it's very similar to
just your entities these methods weren't
possible before 0 11 because a lot of
yeah brokers into the client into worker
so before then these types of semantics
weren't possible you could you can try
them all on top of tactic but there are
certain corner cases that works or the
where you'll always get results always a
possibility that messages can be other
border I won't get into details but that
basically it's related to how we try to
work and think on tonight so this is the
salt so before we get into the guts of
transactions tactic on to the message
delivery support so most once is the
most important one is is a recipient
messages expire never get it a good
example is a game client and server
where you don't you don't care about
every message delivered you don't care
about the latest so it's using the
protocol and which you know it doesn't
have almost acknowledgement stuff built
into it and sending them using it of
course what's best for some and answer
are basically same thing model with
Katherine you're sending any operating
for acknowledgments before incentive net
at least once it's what most people want
to use and it's basically sending
message waiting room acknowledgement
doesn't come back and we retry sending
that message so there's a possibility
you can send that message worth once and
don't mainly you can just just accept
that or and oil deduplication in some
way so that can be a and exactly once is
the holy grail and message delivery
standings and I have any poison cedar
because exactly once a message delivery
if you want to get relief
control is not possible so how does this
technically that they have exact what's
so let me let me explain that a little
work so there is a famous province of
two generals Byzantine generals problem
that says exactly ones message delivery
is possible between two parties where
failures of communication impossible so
I think this is fairly definitive but
what what we're actually due to chapter
is his violating this rule because we're
doing sputtered things at a higher level
so in every class you know you might be
learning about the TCP where things like
response recipe protocol at least once
with TCP and then you know they might
talk about this at that level guarantees
that the messages hold the process once
sort of received ones process once send
once and move to once the destination
you can't make their parent to be a very
low level you need a higher level of
abstraction and a more of application
has specific point immunity make that
kind of thing a reality so that that's
the key basically so exactly once
message to agree a little level it's
impossible
but exactly when to processing at a
higher level using a bunch of tricks or
maybe a lot of the they used to make
exactly once delivered look like as
possible as possible so some of the
things were thinking are
retries until we get MacDonald as very
similar to at least one semantics so
will retry messages
acknowledgement is sent back to the
client we have David sources so when the
message ends up his destination we have
some sort of where to
that message is already consented so
this is kind of deduplication tackling
or and the last thing is we can
guarantee that messages are not
processed more than once there are a
couple little Petri to her that I'm
going to show you the excitement so here
is the basic breakdown of transactions
within cactus so you have one thing that
you need over here quickly so the
transaction coordinator is basically a
subprocess upfronts and one of many
brokers and it's communicating with
their client mobius board is per
transaction it has an internal
transaction transaction
sorry story you have control messages
[Music]
second these are visiting caps at the
end of the Target Center reduces to
signaled answering that pay anything
before these control messages was
processed you have a transaction like
this is similar to a consumer group ID
it basically differentiates this program
from another transactional program and
and also plans off any duplicates of
that program that might try and trample
over the messages at your processes so
if you get a pretty sad example two
programs running with the same IP will
guarantee that under 100 actually
committed the transaction at a time so
they can't commit in time times at the
same time and obviously you lose a lot
of guarantee that exactly wants trying
to give you and the way about it and the
way that works is by there's a
generation of person
for every second of a transaction the
transaction Papa versus the increasing
numbers it's a pendant
so another transactional applications
Rises going it's going to color pencils
off and saw the older generation and say
you know background transaction under a
new player is entropy and were any day
they never new application will resume
from the latest committed offsets that
were sort of it will consume the last
offsets so those creatures are able
transaction and tack currently or I have
no producers multiple partition comic
rights and consumer media and isolation
public so producers are really easy to
explain so all the transactions on the
client the client respective are built
into the these cattle producer API so
you have a client here joining in
cluster and I think is generated by by
the tech cluster for you it's kind of
like that assessment and then where then
you have a sequence number that's one to
one for every partition it introduces
nation you have a systems number so
you're sending the person that secure
from zero this producer editing verbal
receives it and persistent into a
partition
along with that metadata and now the
burger is expecting and that's a message
which would be which would have a
suspense for this particular partition
but when something happens where the
broker is trying to knowledge that
asbestos was persistent and that doesn't
go through the clients going to retry
and
if it's gonna send the exact same
information but instead of feeling the
broker can simply say well that's a
shame it's still a successful request we
made but you didn't stop or any we're
trying to send that message already
happen so signals that there's a
duplicate already if it's sent a nice
number if there's like a gap this is
like a try to send it to you before that
would be the fatal exception of the
transaction everything would be rolled
back so this is and multiple initiative
topic rights are required that process
and all the information all the messages
that transaction all the messages that
we consume from our source topic
I've been bred make sure all these
things happen and then in one one
operation so this is this is basically a
it's a it's a two-phase commit so the
happen is that it will think the
transaction log with the message say and
once once that's a big dollars with that
transaction log damaged in control
messages to all the topics for producing
too and we can also convenient that all
the little messages be consumed have
been read and we do this all at once and
all or nothing operation depending one
of these limits fails and obviously the
whole transaction is valid anymore such
needs to be rolled back once they all
happen successfully have been in a
transaction is committed and everything
is and might be read isolation level is
for downstream consumers up
turns out our club so we described a
simple consumer to transform our
produced before a hesitancy factor
cluster and it has to be consumed from
produces to get these guarantees so
assuming that the transaction was
successful in any other transaction
screen is really consuming petitions you
have produces it looks for if it has
this setting of isolation to be
committed then it knows to wait for this
control message to show up before it
starts consuming messages because it
only wants messages are part of a
successful transaction so the opposite
setting for this not to buy is read
uncommitted that's basically the old
standard way of consuming new chapter
which is basically as mass as possible
finance another client consistency 13 to
nothing but yes that's how that works
so transactional workloads are actually
very fast and in the design papers that
Catherine created when they implemented
so many semantics they they did a
comparison where they the good they
picked a good interval to keep in
transactions like a certain level of
match messages is a transaction the
overhead of a transaction was negative
different over time the performance
penalty that you paid though is is in
the end latency of the year with the
overall pipeline so 20 years is a
transactional application though
committed is some sort of interval
whether it's based on time messages
release time and that
the latency you're gonna see at the end
of this pipeline is going to be an
aggregate of all the latest GOP
transaction two minutes
it has to command to hold that before
the next one so this is what you gotta
watch out for when when using this no
longer a lot of typing so here's how a
packet capture implements this is very
similar to the wave Kappa streams does
it itself is basically a happening right
here where the every 100 milliseconds
but the poem is chemistry it will try to
commit all of these messages so what it
does as messages and through the
transaction extinct or just to be model
as a flow as well the messages are atoms
in the transaction produced and then you
have a little bucket you're waiting for
the acknowledgment for every messenger
messenger consuming and then when it
comes time to data points this is
interval elapsed the speed transact and
we have to we have to do a couple things
in order to make sure that works
properly and I'm going to go through
that work so the grab stage this is the
example of the ground state transaction
the status as a bearish versus time and
it has a significant which is basically
signaling wanna the function so this is
the transaction open now as receiving
messages from people mailbox they
committed some understanding one for
responsive to and then elapses and
the way that is wind open signal
multitude is transaction graph states
like when to stop receiving more
messages is by sending another message
to ourself
this is Kennedy we're modeling supremacy
within Anaka one instead of actually
closing overseas and mutating state
which creates all the most aggressive
positions are we simply send an eternal
message to our mailbox this is the
message that will actually start the
transaction
any messages addressed transaction will
not be Carter sir captain's message
about the parlor transaction in fact
this message itself when it's processed
clevis stage actually suspends the back
preferences no more messages actually
entered the mailbox so at this stage so
yes those but the only difference he
really said we just released to have
like beds
[Music]
are you going